so going back to when you were trying to
get an agent and you finally get an
agent and you you're excited because you
had Gary Coleman's agent or something
yeah Mark Randall yeah you said in the
book the agent says you want to meet
Gary Coleman and you're like [ __ ] yeah
sure why not I want to meet anyone who
has a career and Gary Coleman was one of
the biggest stars in the world you know
yes and uh you go to the meeting and
he's coming on to you and he invites you
up to his hotel room his beautiful
Penthouse hotel room because he's Gary
Coleman he has a lot of money and you're
not even thinking that he's interested
in you sexually and I was a virgin so I
wasn't even thinking about that right so
you were like isn't this nice Gary
Coleman wants me to come up to his room
you were completely naive about it right
oh yeah he held my hand and I was like
he's so cute and he had a suit on and he
told me that I reminded
he told me I reminded him of Kimberly
from Different Strokes and I was like
oh my God if I could only be on
Different Strokes you know right and
Mark came up with us too and they had
the presidential suite and then we went
into the room and then Mark disappeared
though they had a whole move Mark
disappears from the room leaves you
alone with Gary Coleman oh that's so
dark it is such a dark story yeah and
you're sitting there on the bed with him
right and uh yeah I think he was like
sit down like it was very sweet like so
and then then he's like she's like
tickling me a little in this and that I
was like here stop you know like I was
trying to be polite and stuff I'm a
polite Catholic girl in a virgin so I'm
not even thinking about I'm naive about
anything about that but Gary Coleman
started to get really aggressive with
you and you say he grabbed your ankles
oh and started holding on to your ankle
and then was bouncing on the bed trying
to land on top of you yeah and I I can't
even imagine that story I mean that's he
was I was like then he was like trying
to kiss me and get on top of me I was
like no Gary stop so I push him off then
I would get off the bed then he would
bounce on the bed jump jump jump and
wrap himself around me then I would like
fling him
and then he got on top of me and was
trying to you know I was like Gary stop
but I I I I guess because of his size I
I didn't feel physically threatened but
then yeah I finally would he was it was
going on and on repeating I would throw
him off he would get back on throw him
off in his dialysis machine was in the
room and then finally I throw him off I
was like then I'm really getting out of
breath because it was it was like
athletic and aerobic it was and he was
what about four feet tall and he
probably weighed what uh 50 pounds 60 I
don't know 75 pounds so I mean you're
throwing around 75 pounds it's while
it's you know it's it's it's it's hard I
mean it's difficult so then I finally
got him off and then I go to the
bathroom and then he grabs onto my leg
and I was like David I only kicked him
off like that and then I'd go lock
myself in the bathroom like this and
then he sticks it his hands under the
door and he was like I can see
I love the quote in your book you go I
can see you silly Billy yeah it sounds
like a cartoon actually but so how did
you get out of the room when you left
the bathroom did you just like run out
the door I just kind of sprinted out I
think I was probably very polite and
then I I saw Mark Randall and I was like
you gotta watch that client of yours so
I wish I could have stood up for myself
more but I think
um
yeah I I did it that's all I said but
really it's not funny I mean the agent
leaving the room and leaving you alone
you know the whole thing is just so
[ __ ] up and it's also sad yeah